what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine the season 4 premiere
after that incredible Cliffhanger from
season three ladies and Gentlemen please
leave a like and a comment about
anything you want I don't care what it
is is because it just helps out the
video regardless tell us why you ate
this morning tell us about your favorite
animal that you once had tell us about
the love of your life tell us about the
woman or man that you missed out on that
you should have married instead of the
one you're with I don't care what it is
just put it in the comments also full
interaction watch songs will be single
with your own copy of b99 over on our
patreon page thank you so much for all
who have shown your support and have
joined us over there yes super sexy
rejects let's get to it
are you ready for this one Daddy's
daughter Ann is getting divorced Susan
Berger Sue we know the woman in the
middle we should fix her up with
Bernice's son what's his name the doctor
oh Vince and he's not a doctor he's a
pharmacist although that might appeal to
Anne
you're such a cracker it's a kid and who
should we fix him up with huh oh now Sal
you know I'm still getting over the
tragic loss of my wife she was such a
strong female woman with nice heavy
breasts
oh that's my neighbor hey Larry ah hey
grab Greg ah that was it grab not sure
why I have so much trouble remembering
probably because our relationship is so
casual
you've been a little depressed have I
don't need the burrito
[Music]
you deserve this promotion
without going there and get it
give them a hell Greg
yeah
yeah good morning Carly Timmy looks like
you're keeping the machines running
smoothly whatever Carly will be the
first to go
I'd like to be assistant manager
serious oh I just never expected you to
be interested in management I mean you
don't seem like the type of person who's
really interested in the leadership
roles really what I'm very hard working
yeah when you're not totally blazed I
assure you that's not me okay tell that
to the account blanchula t-shirt that
you were rocking last week
hello go to location one now
Maya Rudolph
I can't hear you can you hear me
I can't hear you I think my engine's too
loud
I think we should talk at her
okay has anyone questioned your current
identity either in person or online no
pop quiz Greg where did you go to
college Ohio State where I majored in
Communications
uh Die Hard wrong Jake's favorite movie
is die hard I asked you for Larry's
favorite movie two people can have the
same favorite movie they can but they
don't Larry's favorite movie is Failure
to Launch oh no I'm sorry but it looks
like Larry and Greg will be in Florida
indefinitely Pop Quiz Larry who's a
female lead and Failure to Launch Sarah
Jessica Sarah Jessica Parker man
it's like you want to die
you were right it's the job it keeps me
focused well good I'm glad to hear it
yep now if you'll excuse me I gotta
drive this [ __ ] back to work right
oh sorry this is the ikura [ __ ] 5000.
ATVs are so fun I once flipped one over
oh okay Jimmy figgis where the hell are
you
[Music]
oh Larry
I am off Hong Kong I don't know where
the horn is
yeah with the ATVs the only thing you're
selling is a huge pile of bunk how did
you get here so fast you were walking I
was power walk
after we met the Marshall you said
something very strange it was
squirtingly wasn't it no something much
stranger right
I guess the combination on the first try
69 69 because I hate this stupid place
and I've got to get out I mean this
town's claim to fame is that its Mayors
keep dying and no one knows why that's
insane
snap out of it
and get a job okay I wonder who's hiring
hey everyone I just want to introduce
you to our new assistant manager Larry
sherbert
no no way no
I believe in the power of nicknames
smile face senorita swag
guys can I get real with you for one sec
I used to work for a real stickler
type of guy that just got off on telling
me what to do one time he invaded my
private space and stole my stuff why
would he do that perhaps he had a good
reason wrong Mr Fart he was a jerk and
he sucked but he was the one who
motivated me to get off my ass and get
this job so in a way we really have him
to thank for all this happening
give it up
you have zero experience I guess you
lied on your resume Greg you Stoney
macaroni of course I lied up my resume
lives are a lie I straight up said I was
that guy who landed the plane on the
Hudson
someone just volunteered to be djb day
here at the Fun Zone we live by one rule
when it's your birthday you are always
cool parents and kids are all the same
watch
as I do a dance
to your name
Derek
Eric
well then I guess it's time for your
next task you're gonna need to change
into what
no
every time a go-kart Drives By I want
you to scream and this is very important
miso corny you can ruin my job Larry but
that's not all I've got here in Florida
I've got a life I've got friends you
sure about that honestly Estelle oh no
go right now Larry that's my walking
Booth I have to get my file no you will
never get them whoa
oh geez we got bigger problems this is
gonna break the internet
you cannot put that on the internet
I was hoping that would happen
[Music]
there's no car drivers are merciless you
have to get that video can we please
just press pause on this fight and work
together yes on one condition you stay
the hell away from my walking group The
Walking group meant nothing to me that's
even worse
what did you find that much the camera
was behind her look at her calf it's a
tattoo of Jesus punching Bin Laden in
the nuts nice
okay that's the most common tattoo we
give so these photos tell us nothing
actually you know what that's a high
school graduation right Dan Marino High
class of 2003. Marina hi home of the
Dolphins I suspect no pet detectives
town was real
you guys got Inked or what no I already
have a tattoo what where why how when I
will never talk about it again
[Music]
me
it's on his butt we're not cops anymore
how are we going to get access to those
files easy I walk in there dressed as an
exterminator say I'm from one two three
Pest Removal secretaries like never
heard yet then I'm like listen Lassie
it's best to let me speak with your
principal I hear it I'm gonna drop the
accent she takes me to see the principal
you walk in behind me and download the
file hey there I'm the Exterminator here
for the uh you're here for the snakes
all right oh God
I found our suspect her name is Jordan
carveden and she lives on Shula Lane how
did the snake room where we'll go
Miss Carlton you don't know yeah I do I
got you on video looking like a couple
of dumbasses
I don't care about you a great viral
video like that could fetch me 10 grand
and do you know what type of tanning bed
I could get for that kind of money a
mid-range one not necessarily your can
is great as is you look like an evenly
stained dick all right dude keep it in
your pants like I get why you're into
this and I could see something going on
with us later what if we gave you the
ten thousand dollars make it 15 you got
a deal Jesus meet us tonight at the Fun
Zone eight o'clock I will shoot her
don't worry I still have a few tricks up
my sleeve the only thing I need you to
do I'm not going to show you my tattoo
come on just give me a hint is it an
antique boat is it a musket is it me on
a dragon
fifteen thousand dollars cash you just
stuck a few twenties around a bunch of
corn dog coupons here's the phone
you're gonna have to catch me first
oh my God you really thought that would
work this video is going viral I'm gonna
demand they send us to different cities
because I don't want you anywhere near
me I swapped the phones
sorry bye Greg
hey he didn't know you swapped the phone
lastly hold 13 on the mini golf course
is missing so tell all the players to
just he became assistant manager
promotion damn Greg you are killing it
as assistant manager I mean having the
idea to have people come in at 9 00 a.m
that has really helped business yes that
is when the sign says we're open
I need to talk to this particular
associate and apologize for saying he
half-assed his ATV sales technique well
that's very nice but I've moved on and
I'm with customers so thanks these
machines are death traps if you purchase
one you will be maimed
I've looked over what you've got given
your resources very impressive but I
know it'll take me months to find
figures but we'll find him faster if we
work together what if we don't find
figures what are figures
finds US ah
we post this video and use it to lure
figures down here making ourselves in
debate and once Vegas is here we take
him down climb out of America's steaming
orifice and go home I like the way
you're thinking Greg it's hold
Captain Raymond oh [ __ ] now come and get
us figus not a doctor oh Holt Night
Rises it's going down
going down dude Amy Rosa Terry were
hilarious dude let's do Charles oh my
God some of those gags of Charles so
good the B stories amongst them all yeah
really kind of overshadowed the a story
with Holt it was really crazy how Scully
and Hitchcock like took the lead this
time I know and they actually got to
prove themselves as something Fearless
moving like I cried a little bit for the
both of them I have never been brought
to such tears on a Brooklyn Nine-Nine
episode until now no and I can't imagine
ever being moved such as such like in
this way again you know he talks
sincerely for one minute I'm sorry I
didn't mean to make a mockery
of this
very emotional episode featuring the
entire cast of the show
are you gonna talk sincerely about this
episode John we have a very limited time
yes I enjoyed it quite a bit it's very
nice to be back with the Brooklyn nine
nine times up John I missed it in our
Bible way too slow uh just channeling my
whole speed it up uh good speed up the
talk and it was funny and it was good to
see yorma and uh you know
let's talk faster uh uh come on I gotta
stand on my inner coin okay Brooklyn
Nine-Nine uh really funny jokes uh some
really great uh you know like
banter-based comedy some good site gags
with the ATV really like the walking
group
um and uh Jorma tacon from The Lonely
Island always funny to see him and Andy
Samberg you know bouncing off each other
him and uh and Andre Brower bouncing off
each other was really funny as well and
loved the uh you know just reorientation
of the story them trying to make it work
in Florida but then not making it work
in Florida and deciding to go after
figures instead plus we got Maya Rudolph
Cameo amazing what do you think
I think the exploration of an identity
crisis is something really profound and
perhaps deeper rooted and perhaps
something of a reflection of what the
the writing staff is going through
oftentimes as artists in this field we
feel like and I say we because I'm
encompassing John and I as and that
symptom and posture syndrome and you
know it's like sometimes you're walking
through life feeling like you've got to
be something you're not and oftentimes
you end up settling for less and having
to compromise and also living in a life
of fear so I thought this episode was
actually quite powerful and how it
portrayed something that I think a lot
of people can really identify with
because in a lot of ways most of us are
living in our own witness protection
program where we are hiding behind a
veil of oh my God yeah this is the job
that I have this is what's most
important to me this is the career this
is the money this is about keeping it
safe but there's no such thing as
Security in this world that is a lie
told to you by the corporate yeah by the
security companies who want your money
it is not secure
so go out there and take chances and put
yourself out on the internet I think I
got a lot from this episode and I feel
like it's going to change my my life and
the journey that I go down now after
this this is profound
and neither of us will ever be the same
again no you know I'm getting highlights
it's the first day of the rest of our
lives you know I would love to work at
like a mini golf course or an arcade
though because I I love going to like
Chuck E cheese or Sherman Oaks Castle
Park Sam I'm not a big fan of Dave and
Buster's I feel like that is uh kind of
a mockery of what the the essence and
the joy and Nostalgia element is it's
it's like I feel like people kind of go
there to be adults and hook up and I
don't like it I I feel like now you
should go for the games and I think
there's a big part of Dave and Buster's
that doesn't feel like they're there for
the actual games I feel like they're
there for the beer more than they are
for the games I've been there with
groups of people like that where they
just sit around the table drinking beer
for like two hours barely touching the
games and that's a real turn off to me
to me it's more like this you know being
a grown ass man walking in there's a
bunch of little kids and I look like I
don't belong that is the joy right there
that's actually a really serious sincere
thought that's true when I go there and
I want to play basketball I'm like this
freaking 10 year old Latino kids taking
forever
just just like come on quit hogging the
basketball game yeah I want to play the
basketball game it's more my eye line
where the basket is and then if you
shove that kid you look like the [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then these groups of like
18 people all like let's play Mario Kart
racing again yeah like cheese like share
it share it you freaking weird High
School prep white boys stop it there are
only three terminals you're gonna be
here all night let some of us play yeah
yeah
and also you know you're playing mini
golf and you got those high schoolers
who are just like I'm gonna be like the
wacky guy to make the girls laugh stupid
jackasses you gotta take the game
seriously I hit my ball into the water
it's embarrassing and when we walk in
the water oh how about I take a golf
club to your head you dumb 15 year old
kid beat you to death right here on
discourse on this astro turf your blood
will be spilled
yeah yeah you know it's not fair but you
know these are the struggles that we
have to endure we have to endure people
yeah
kids just think they can do whatever
they want in places that are kid
appropriate when really you know they
they should learn to get out of the way
for us adult folk you know we want to
play Time Crisis right now or skee ball
or miniature golf and some of us take
the scoring very seriously some of us
are trying to improve our game our putt
game our our getting the ball between
the things on the windmill game without
getting you know hit and sometimes I
want to get a good doll prize too and
that requires a lot of tickets yeah so
you know and oftentimes yeah do I end up
spending more money to try to win the
tickets than I would for me to just buy
the actual item that I'm trying to win
of course usually four times the amount
of money but it's about earning that
that's right
converting tickets into a prize
that is the reward system that every
American should be aiming for in order
to succeed in life
so with that in mind I did think that
this was a delightful episode and I
thought it was funny
and I'm excited for them to get back
into you
the the routine of actually copping it
out I imagine next episode we'll go back
to actual b99 see what the life is like
uh but yeah this was a fun episode fun
episode overall that's right we should
go into witness protection I didn't find
it hilarious there were some hilarious
moments
it's okay
it's never hilarious adjusting to a New
Life
no it's not and learning profound
lessons about yourself
when I lived in Puerto Rico for a year
it was really tough when I realized that
Logan Paul is my next door neighbor wow
and
I was like why'd he build the house that
is only slightly a few inches taller
than mine and I felt like it was to make
a point it's a slight use specifically
and uh but you know saving money on
taxes is nice you know you get a real
good tax break and I feel like the
people of Puerto Rico are really happy I
was there yes and they appreciate it so
that Logan Paul's there Bad Bunny I feel
like I think they're all very very happy
that we were all there yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're gonna be on the new Bad
Bunny album right jobs
we help out the economy and the lower
and Working Class People of Puerto Rico
yeah so I I kind of want to move back I
mean I still got the property multiple
properties I don't even let people rent
them out make sure everyone anybody yet
nobody trespasses yeah they are only for
your use if you should decide you ever
want to use that and tear down a whole
neighborhood
and whatever some people gotta live on
the streets or find some shelter it's
not my problem that's their problem they
should have bought needed property they
should have bought more houses when they
had the chance I know we're being lazy
people in Puerto Rico whatever you're
called just make that house Puerto Rico
people Puerto Rico ho so yeah I built a
quite a full strip and uh it's glorious
and once a year I take vacations over
there
just admire the quiet isolation of the
island
every once in a while I hear some other
people like yum miles away just a crowd
to noise
just like shut up I throw money at them
oh really that's really kind of you I oh
it's it's about a hundred dollars all in
singles yeah yeah yeah and you make them
fight over those singles yeah for your
amusement yeah and they don't really
fight
because they don't really they're corn
and then they don't see the value in
fighting over one dollars
however uh
that's all I'm willing to get
they should see the value in fighting
over I need to pay for my property right
I mean that's that's the American dream
and you pay for my house it's just like
Goring somebody over over a Washington
but you let me know people of Puerto
Rico
what I can do to contribute to the
community but I will not leave uh my my
home stays I won't leave won't throw
more money real rejects businesses
registered there too yeah good tax
breaks yeah get an offshore offshore
accounts Greg Alba LLC also registered
there too Greg Corp Greg Corp yeah it's
great savings let's do a patreon
Maria Hammond Maria we want to shout you
out because I was thinking if I had to
go into the witness protection program
who would I want to be my neighbor it
would definitely be you absolutely
because you are the most generous
out of anyone our patreon if we need
something anything I know you are one
knock away hell I might even just need
to stand on my front lawn and be like
iced tea I know you would do it Maria so
that's why I would love for you to in
case you missed what we were talking
about a little bit ago I would love for
you to live next to me in Puerto Rico
yeah come on down so if you and I can
just staycation together in Puerto Rico
oh man imagine the fun we would have
we'd be up all night together watching
Rick and Morty playing it on multiple
televisions taking up the electricity of
the entire entire I don't know what it
is a a nation a a capital A a country
country really Puerto Rico is a country
you know it's an Avenue
no it's a wonderful
man this is crazy American Property
sanity Insanity America is a country
everything else is a small town so yeah
everything else is America adjacent
they're they're just want to be America
anyway look that's awesome subject here
Maria you be the perfect neighbor
because also you know if I'm having like
a really hard night and I'm feeling
emotional I know I could just wake you
up literally you probably just let me
walk in your door and be like hey Maria
H
wake up
drop some water on your face and I know
you would respond positively because
your love for us is unconditional get an
air horn
really hard that's how we would wake you
up really hard to find someone who would
be as loyal and compassionate
of the neighbor as you surely it'd
actually be fun to live with you we
could have an animal farm oh cool buy
some snakes feed some rabbits to them I
blame you for the guilt I feel over
killing the rabbits and you would take
that guilt on because you are that good
of a name of a human being
you got soul and you're super bad super
bad can I say she's super bad
anyway Maria on a very sincere note
um I hope that
you can have a positive holiday season
yeah and that this Halloween you could
dress up like the fish from the shape of
water
your favorite costume only costs
like 200 if in Puerto Rico uh on
silicone yeah but in uh in Americas
only people like John could afford it no
that's right and you can't borrow my
shape of water costume all right no it's
fitted to my specific body type not many
people get the Richard Jenkins costume
but I was pretty impressed with how you
pulled it off I love Richard Jane don't
underestimate me we're gonna get the
fish outfit but you just you got the
suit the glasses the bald caps that's
right man and I was like he's doing it
man he looks like Richard Jenkins that's
right man call me the Jinx in fact if
you just like hide your hair yeah look
at that Richard James over here Richard
Jenkins oh hey look at me guys know
Richard Jenkins did I just become a much
better actor all of a sudden hilarious
Republican activist that's right you
guys have no idea he loves he loves
republicanism he does he does have you
seen his speech at the White House
correspondence you're right man oh he's
the funniest guy
roasting bite and non-stop hilarious
Trump 2028 anyway Maria I hope you can
host the next White House Correspondents
dinner thank you guys for being here and
uh thank you Maria for being the best of
them all every one of them you're better
than them all if any other patrons are
watching the shout out you strive to be
more like Maria
you're the best around
you mean amount amount
say Hammond Hammond you're the best
Hammond
No One's Gonna ever break it down
or something else that rhymes I made the
shot weird we're done you made it weird
[Music]